If we only were to focus on two
generations let's say for a dominant and recessive
trait in a pedigree, we could really be
missing information. Take this example here. I have
two very small pedigrees of just an immediate
family and they show the same affected inheritance
pattern where one child, one daughter is affected.
But one of these pedigrees is for a recessive
trait that both parents have an allele for, but
they're unaffected and then they pass both of those
recessive alleles on to the daughter. And the other
pedigree is from a very new spontaneous mutation that's
causing a dominant trait but the question is, can
you tell the difference? I can't. The only way
to distinguish these two possibilities would be to zoom
out on both pedigrees and fill out as much family
information as we can. This family history is going to
be able to help us figure out which one
of these is a recessive trait pedigree and which
one of these is a spontaneous mutation that's caused a
new dominant trait. For example this pedigree on the
right is most likely the pedigree of a recessive trait.
Because we now see that there's a family history.
Unaffected parents with affected offspring, the traits skip generations and
we see it on both sides of the
family. Whereas the other pedigree is mostly likely caused
from our spontaneous mutation and the new dominant trait
because we don't have any family history of it,
whatsoever. Although again, this could still possibly be a
result of limited information. And maybe we just need
to zoom out even further to tell if it's
actually another possibility of it being a recessive pedigree
as well. The point is, is that any time we're really doing this in real life.
We try to get as much information as
possible and specifically when we're trying to distinguish
these two scenarios, what we're looking for is a family history
of the condition. Meaning that you've got maybe more than one affected
sibling or parent or close relative, or even possibilities of
[UNKNOWN]
relationships. Effectively reproduction with close relatives.